at first the FBI were wary of Samuel
littles claimed that he'd killed 93
people now they say they do believe him
confirming him as America's most
prolific serial killer even more
chilling his sketches of the young women
he murdered police hope these pictures
will help identify who these victims
were in many cases decades after their
deaths victims like the woman he calls
Mary Ann killed in Florida in 1972
confessions reveal what police say is a
photographic memory for the details of
his crimes this woman was murdered in
Kentucky in 1984 and how he met this
woman he says he murdered in Las Vegas
in 1993 the killings took place across
the country and spanned 35 years little
is already serving three life sentences
in prison in California it was the work
of the detective you can hear in these
interviews that began to join the dots
suggest his motive his just killing
there was something in him that liked to
kill and unfortunately he was very good
at finding potential victims many of
those killed by little were originally
ruled as accidents or overdoses some
bodies have never been found the FBI is
asking for the public's help a
combination of DNA and Samuel littles
own words confirming to them the full
horror of his crimes Gregg Milam Sky
News Los Angeles